these mass graves in my qatar in
northern ethiopia unearthed what the u.n
says could be war crimes committed in
the tigrai conflict
a joint ethiopian and u.n human rights
investigation says rebels from tigrai
killed more than 200 ethnic amharas here
in november last year
the conflict has now expanded well
beyond tigray into neighboring amhara
and afar regions
and it's been devastating for civilians
the u.n report found in the year-long
war eritrean soldiers who backed
ethiopia's federal army as well as
ethiopian government soldiers anti-grand
rebels have committed widespread crimes
including rape torture and killings of
civilians
all parties to the tigre conflict have
committed violations of international
human rights humanitarian and refugee
law
some of these may amount to war crimes
and crimes against humanity ethiopia's
government has largely welcomed the
report while expressing its serious
reservations about aspects of the
findings
its promise to set up a task force to
investigate the allegations
while rebels in tigray said the report
is flawed citing the involvement of the
ethiopian human rights commission
but on the ground the conflict is
intensifying t grand rebels say they
have captured two northern towns on a
major highway leading to the capital
addis ababa
prime minister abi ahmed has urged
ethiopians to unite and fight against
the rebels and has warned that attempts
to make ethiopia like libya and syria
will not succeed abi ahmed who was
re-elected in a landslide victory in
june is facing mounting pressure to end
the war from ethiopia's largest
humanitarian aid donor the united states
as the war approaches its one year
anniversary
the united states and others cannot
continue business as usual
relations with the governor of of
ethiopia
the extraordinary
partnership we have enjoyed is not
sustainable while the military conflict
continues to expand
threatening the stability and the unity
of one of africa's most influential
countries
the biden administration has suspended
ethiopia from a crucial trade agreement
with the u.s very significant decision
by the united states it is important to
understand that it hasn't happened yet
in other words as a july there's a
january one
date at which it may become effective if
there is no movement towards peace in
ethiopia and if that happens
i think ethiopia is
likely to lose
about a quarter of a billion dollars
and that could mean more hardship for
ethiopians the u.n investigation only
looked into reports of abuse until late
june when the rebels regained much of
tigray it does not include any attacks
or civilian abuse since then
priyanka gupta al-jazeera
let's go live now to samuel gerachu
who's in addis ababa uh samuel first off
what should we make of prime minister
abi ahmed's response to this u.n
lead report which has found serious
human rights violations some potentially
constituting war crimes
well to begin with at the ethiopian
human rights commission is part of the
ethiopian government it's a government
agency
they the head has been saying that they
really want to
investigate more they don't have the
resources to do so uh to the credit of
the un that uh took
the ethiopian human rights commission as
a partner but again the ethiopian side
hasn't said much but the allegations
stand that all actors including ethiopia
eritrea and the tplf
stand accused of some of the worst by
human rights violations
in the history of this travel nation
even by ethiopian standard it's very
troubling
talk to me about the latest developments
on the ground there how serious is an
escalation what we're seeing now with
the tplf taking towns uh it says which
are on the road to the capital
well ethiopia hasn't really acknowledged
the fact that tpnf has taken over
cambodia an important city and desi
but the fact that
local government is telling residents to
register their weapons and defend their
neighborhoods
makes you believe that there's something
happening that the government hasn't
spoken of
that the tpi left remained to be a
threat the prime minister spoke to his
ministers yesterday highlighting the
fact according to him according to his
perspective that the tpl
is a terrorist organization that needs
to be defeated
but here we are
and people are shell-shocked by the
fast-changing environment of ethiopia
the u.s embassy has told its residents
to leave ethiopia because of this we
know that the tplf has allied with other
uh armed groups with other fighters how
has the tplf and its allies been able
to make these sorts of gains
well the historical fact is the ola the
oromo liberation front which half of the
leadership is
one of them is the minister a senior
minister inside uh prime minister abby's
government
they fought the tplf for 27 years and
accused them of all kinds of violations
including human rights and lack of
democracy and for them to find a common
enemy by itself is a milestone
but how long that relationship will
stand is an open uh debate
all right thank you for that update
there samuel get you an ari sababa for
us